[Music]
the EU has imposed sanctions on Russia
following its actions in Ukraine these
include the violation of Ukrainian
sovereignty and illegal annexation of
crimea and sevastopol by russia in flows
of fighters and weapons from russia into
eastern ukraine a foreign policy tool
the measures do not target the Russian
population they aim to bring about a
change in Russian policy
- what Ukraine the EU remains ready to
reverse its decisions and Bri engage
with Russia when it changes its policy
including by starting to contribute
actively and without ambiguity to
finding a solution to the Ukrainian
crisis the European Union regularly
reassesses the sanctions and
communicates openly about them I always
said and I can repeat it today sanctions
in themselves are not an objective or a
tool and I think that everybody wishes
that this situation can be overcome as
soon as possible but this needs to be
linked to an improvement of the
situation on the ground in the east of
Ukraine
following a decision taken by the member
states with unanimity the economic
sanctions will remain in place until the
complete implementation of the Minsk
agreements this includes restoring
Ukrainian control of its borders in the
east 152 persons involved in undermining
Ukraine's territorial integrity are
subject to asset freezes and visa bans
37 entities have had their assets frozen
in the EU
additionally economic sanctions include
limiting access to EU capital markets
for Russian state-owned financial
institutions and restricting access to
certain sensitive technologies
particularly in the oil and military
sectors the EU has not limited the
export of foodstuffs to Russia that
decision was taken by the Russian
authorities
[Music]